(upbeat cheerful music)
No look is complete without the perfect pair of earrings.
But earrings weren't always
just a fashion statement for women.
Did you know, Egyptian males
were actually among the first to wear earrings?
Earrings date back more than 7,000 years to ancient Asia.
In the 13th century,
ear piercings were banned by the Catholic Church.
But they made a comeback during the Renaissance
in the 14th century.
The early 1900s gave birth to the clip-on earrings.
The '50s saw an uptick in teenage ear piercing,
and the single stud became the go to look.
And we have the memorable scene
in the movie "Grease" to thank for that trend.
In the '60s and '70s,
we saw the invention of the piercing gun.
In the '80s, punk rock culture
brought on a wave of gauged and spike earrings.
And in the '90s,
it was dominated by bamboo, hoops, and name plate earrings.
Today, it estimated that over 80% of Americans
have an ear piercing.
One of the biggest trends in the last decade
is to go far beyond the lobes and into the upper ear.
And the late fashion icon, Coco Chanel said,
"Jewelry is an ornament."
So which earrings are you rocking today?
(audience clapping)
Okay, joining us now is a true superstar in her own right.
She is a professional piercer and jewelry designer
who has pierced the ears of everyone
from, mm, Blake Lively, Charlize Theron,
Gwyneth Paltrow, Rihanna.
I mean, I am so star struck by this woman.
I can't even handle it
and I'm gonna get to meet her right now.
It's Maria Tash!
(audience clapping)
Now, you have studios all over the world now.
Yeah, I'm global.
We have studios in the Middle East,
as well as London, and Dublin,
and Miami, we just opened, Dallas is coming.
But it's around the world now. It's amazing.
I mean, when Rihanna comes in and is like,
"Let's do something," what is it that you look at?
And then where do you work from?
What's that process?
I was really honored 'cause she's an organic client
and she had the Met Gala,
and she asked us to design custom earrings for the Met Gala,
so that got put out there.
I was so glad, but I love Rihanna.
She takes a lot of risks and likes a lot of what I wear.
So I know she likes a lot of movement.
I know what piercings she has.
So it's about scaling things that she likes to her ear
and finding new, wonderful, hidden placements.
Like she just got the Hidden Tash Rook,
it's a piercing I patented,
as well as a Tash Helix, an another piercing I patented.
And so it's great.
She takes a lot of risks
and wears a lot of big, bold things.
So I love that.
(upbeat cheerful music)